when you go to make a movie with robert
and the way he works and his off the
attention to authenticity obviously you
see it all on set you know in your
producer you you understand everything
but what was it actually like watching
the finished film versus maybe your
expectations when you started making the
project
it was
i was uh
overwhelmed and it was incredibly
emotional it uh
uh um back a lot of memories
from
from the the irish mud when we were
crawling around there
um
uh
there are
uh
when you shoot a movie this way it's uh
since there are no cuts what you see
was exactly what happened and how i
remembered it so
um sometimes when you watch a movie um
once after it's gone through a year of
editing and um
in in
reshaping sometimes it uh it can change
quite a bit but this was very again
there are very few scenes in the movie
with cuts
um
uh so it it uh it was very much the way
i remembered it before i jump into some
specifics on the movie i am curious if
someone has never seen anything you've
done what is the first thing you want
them watching and why
the northmen of course
it's the
um
it is the i've never been more
involved in a project deeper involved in
a project i've
had the privilege of of being part of
this this journey since the genesis
um
i've been dreaming of making a viking
movie
for
well since i was a kid
um
and about 10 years ago lars knutson the
danish producer and i
teamed up and trying to figure out a way
to to actually make that happen
uh and we were playing around with
different ideas and reading the old
icelandic they had the poetry the old
icelandic sagas and trying to figure out
um
uh which story to base it on
we we knew that we wanted to capture the
essence of those um the kind of the
stark
laconic language the
the harshness of it um but it it
it wasn't until i met rob five years ago
um
coincidentally and it turned out that he
had just been to iceland and
um had fallen in love with the island
and the culture and we started talking
about
norse mythology and viking culture and
and that became
um
well the starting point kind of for this
this this crazy journey what was your
reaction actually when you first saw
robert's other two films were you like
this is the guy
yeah so i was uh
i had i was gonna meet rob five years
ago in new york about
another project and um
i just seen the witch and i was really
really uh blown away by it and again his
attention to details
his the historical accuracy of it uh
it really did feel like i was
transported back in time and uh
and i lars knutson
who is a producing partner on the
northmen
also uh produced that film so i knew
what robert could do with a on a very
very tight it's a
very small budget movie and it's i i i
couldn't believe that when i saw it
because it it's it's the world he
created is so fantastic and so
uh the texture of it it's so rich
um
that it felt like the the
the perfect director for for an uh
an authentic viking uh tale listen
there's a lot of in this movie that's
just fantastic but one of the sequences
that's just it blew my mind was
obviously when you guys are raiding the
village it's this i believe it's 90
seconds continuous um can you sort of
maybe take us through or take me through
uh filming that sequence
it was um
exhausting and challenging and
exhilarating all at the same time it was
a real
uh
treat to shoot a scene like that like a
long sequence like that and just one
long continuous take
um
i've never done that before
action movies just aren't done that way
you it's
as a sequence will have
a gazillion cuts in different angles and
multiple cameras but
to figure out a way to do it
in in just one long shot with one camera
on film
um
it's uh
it sounded like a crazy idea but
i guess it was
because it took a long time we we got
together um
months before shooting the movie to just
plan out the the
the
choreography the the relationship
between
the actors and the camera how how we
would move how the camera would move um
and then and then work and try to
incorporate that into our training
um
so that the
myself and the stunt guys would plan it
and
go through all the different beats all
the different fights within that
sequence
um
and then going out to location as it was
as as the village was being built and
looking at the wall how do you ascend
that wall and how do you
move around and where and we do the hit
on the horse all that kind of stuff so
it was just a tremendous amount of
planning because again when you're
it's also a
my my character's in a berserker state
of mind and so
we had to get through all the technical
aspects of it so that when we're there
shooting it
i can just
stay in that and be your new foot uh
so it was just about doing it over and
over and over again with a sequence like
that how many takes could you actually
do at one time without like running out
of gas if you will
as many as it takes
there are no cuts so you can't really
settle for like oh that wasn't great but
let's move on it and um you just have to
do it till it every single
uh
aspect every single detail
works perfectly this was a i'm sure an
extremely tough project for you to
actually make due to the physical
demands of the role um
is this way of working where this
authenticity that robert goes for
is it sort of like an addiction that you
think you'd want to apply more of this
to like future projects
uh that devotion dedication is
incredibly inspiring
um
and uh
this has been the most extraordinary
journey of my career uh
coming out of that i
uh
i probably i should probably do
something very very different next like
uh i i
just because it was such an amazing
experience i can't try to duplicate that
um it's probably better to go do a
slapstick comedy or something very
different um how long multiple camera
sitcoms or something exactly what i've
spoken to a lot of actors and they talk
about how sometimes they go you know the
performance really it takes everything
out of them and they it takes them a
little while to decompress from the role
how long did it take you after rapping
on filming to sort of feel like yourself
again or were you able to just like flip
a switch
i was able to
i was
we were all very exhausted and relieved
and excited and
to go through that on and also to go
through it in 2020 before the during the
pandemic before the vaccine was out
um with a crew of 400 on a on a
mountaintop in ireland and were
in a pile in the mud shooting it it's
very difficult to do that in a safe
manner obviously
um but we got through it and
so i
it was such a journey um that coming out
of it was
um i i took a
bit of a break after that um
and a bit of a breakdown
uh yeah no i i just uh relaxed and and
and um
you're filled with emotion and and
they're all it's it's a lot going on
because you're
proud
you're it's a sense of accomplishment
you're uh relieved through it you're
sad because um an experience like this
is incredibly bonding and intense so
sometimes you're a bit um
you feel a bit shell-shocked coming out
of it and and you're
back
in civilization and you sit there and
then now what
um and also the it's
there's so much adrenaline and
excitement and uh um
input
during those months that afterwards uh
it's a little bit like everything just
feels a bit
bland
um
so i yeah i i i i i it um not that i'm
i'm definitely not a method actor and it
wasn't hard to
it wasn't like i walked around and felt
like
beowulf
on the streets of new york but um i
could definitely feel the
the
uh the impact that that experience had
on me
what does it mean to you to be number
one on the call sheet and did you feel
like
an added sense of responsibility because
you are you know you're the lead in the
movie and you're also producing and you
have this big crew could you sort of
maybe talk about that
i try to approach
every project with the same amount of
professionalism and commitment
regardless if it's a lead role or a
small cameo
[Music]
i think
we were very lucky on this movie it was
an extraordinary
um extraordinarily committed crew
a lot of the crew members were fans of
robert eggers and were excited to be
there and and and excited to tell the
story and build this world
um
um
i i i never felt that i had to
uh motivate anyone it was i never felt
that someone was
not incredibly excited to be the part of
this uh
so uh i i never had to kind of step into
that role where
it wasn't quite working everyone was
super fired up and and we were all like
moving in the same direction i'm sure
there's going to be some people that
have not
seen a trailer or um or know that much
about the movie
at least two people uh what do you
what's most important to you to let
people know about the film like is there
one or two things you want people to
really know about it i think um
if
you haven't seen
a trailer and if you know nothing about
the movie
that's fantastic just go see it and
don't listen to my annoying voice
i think
some of the
strongest cinematic experiences i've had
are when i step into the theater and i
don't know anything about the movie i
think that's great so i don't want
people to
feel something or take away something or
just
go in there
with open eyes and i i just hope that
it's uh it's going to be a
uh
a thrilling journey your fellow cast
mates are all so incredible in their
roles um could you i guess it's so funny
though with nicole playing your mom in
this oh um could you sort of talk a
little bit about working with nicole and
what do you really enjoy working what
what
what is maybe your favorite part of
working with her as an actor
nicole and i
um
formed a very strong connection a bond
on
big little lies uh it was a
very difficult journey the
um
obviously a very dark relationship
incredibly
rewarding is so well written and so
interesting that relationship but but
but again physically and mentally very
very difficult
um
this is
a very different relationship we're not
husband and wife or mother son but it's
equally uh dark and um
and disturbing
um
in
in going there going so
deep and so into something so dark it's
it's it's absolutely wonderful when you
have a partner whom
you trust
um
and uh
having had that i think
we hit the ground running on the
northmen because we spent a year
together on on big little lies and knew
each other so well
um
and at least i was very excited to be
reunited with nicole um
so that that was one of the highlights
of the whole shoot the the very first
day we had was that scene
in her um
chambers where um
my character basically
explains who he is and why he's there
um
in in in after two months of doing big
action set pieces uh
um to have that scene with nicole uh was
was uh very memorable also that scene
has
been awesome so you know what i mean um
i gotta wrap i'm just gonna say man you
are fantastic in this thank you so much
for giving me your time oh thank you so
much
you